Hey, Zachary, what's your background?
What you need? What you need? What you
need?
>> Oh, hello. Um, I'm Eastern Orthodox and
I'm wondering why the book of Enoch is
not in the it's not canon.
>> What kind of Orthodox are you, mister?
>> Um, Serbian, which is Eastern.
>> Okay. Meaning that you're Eastern
Orthodox, not Oriental Orthodox, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Why would Enoch need to be in the
Arcan brother?
>> Um, I don't know. It was in Jude like it
was mentioned.
>> Yeah. But New Testament also references
other writings. For example, 2 Timothy
3:8, Paul mentions a tradition that the
name of the sorcerers are Janice and
Jambre, which you'll find in Jewish
writings at the time of Christ. But just
because he mentions something found in
these writings doesn't mean it's part of
scripture. And Paul also quotes, for
example, [clears throat]
pagan writings in Acts 17:28. And on top
of that, Jude not only quotes Enoch, but
also quotes the assumption of Moses.
Because if you go to Jude and read verse
9, he talks about that Michael and Satan
disputed over the body of Moses. Well,
that comes from a pseudopigraph called
the assumption of Moses.
So, if you're thinking that just because
it's quoted it should be in there, well,
that means there's a lot of books that
should be in there. They're not. Even in
the Old Testament, there's reference to
the book of Jasha.
And then it talks about the wars of
Yahweh. There was a book written about
all the wars that Yahwa had convened and
commissioned as well as records written
by kings and other prophets seers that
are not in the Old Testament. And the
most important thing most important
thing is that if you include Enoch,
you're including a forgery because
supposedly Enoch is the one who came
down and passed down that revelation.
Right.
>> Yeah. What evidence do we have that
Enoch went to heaven, saw heaven, and
came down with the mysteries of heaven,
and had it recorded?
>> Well, other um prophets said that,
didn't they?
>> I'll give you $10 million if you show me
a prophet went to heaven, saw heaven,
and came down because you just said that
Jesus is wrong in John 3:13.
>> Who's a prophet that sort of the
seraraphim? It's like Isaiah. Jesus just
said, "No one has gone up to heaven, but
he who came down from heaven, the son of
man was in heaven." He said, "What?"
Yeah, but Isaiah was there. So, is Jesus
a liar or John is a liar? Let me explain
to you the difference in the Old
Testament. No one went to heaven. They
were on earth and had a vision of heaven
opening up. You can't you don't even
know the difference.
>> Oh, did they see it in a in a dream or
something?
>> Isaiah is on earth and he's having a
vision heaven open. He's on earth. He
doesn't go into heaven. Micaiah in First
Kings 22, he's on earth. He sees heaven
open in a vision or a dream, but he
doesn't go into heaven. Daniel has a
vision. None of them went to heaven.
They were on earth.
It's like Steven filled with the Holy
Spirit in Acts 7 556.
Did he not see the heavens open?
>> And Acts 7, you don't even know that
one, too. Um, isn't X about uh people on
a boat going to like Paul and John on a
boat?
>> What does Acts 7556
have to do with X? I don't know what the
heck you're talking about. Lord, help
me, please. I'm the one.
>> Okay, let me see.
>> Act 7556.
>> 556.
Help me.
>> Was Steven full the Holy Spirit looked
up to heaven and saw the glory of God in
Jesus name. Was he in heaven or did he
looked up to heaven?
>> He looked up to heaven.
>> So where was he, brother? Help me
>> on earth.
>> All right. And then what happened? How
did he see heaven? Did he go up there?
Okay. Read for me.
>> I see heaven open and the son of man
standing in the right hand go.
>> So was he on earth when he saw heaven
open?
>> Yeah.
>> So why would you be that dumb to think
that Isaiah had to be in heaven to see
God's throne in heaven?
I don't know. I haven't um
>> Okay, now coming back to the issue
>> since the book of Enoch says Elijah went
through heaven
and came down with the mysteries and
Jesus says prior to him no one entered
heaven and came down except him who's
from heaven. How can Enoch be written by
Enoch with contradicting John and Jesus?
Well, Enoch has other problems in it.
Like he said that Enoch is the son of
man which is only Jesus as the son of
man. The book of Eno to 71. Yes. The son
of man and Enoch become one and the
same. Yes. Exactly. Now that's why
scholars think that section of Enoch was
added later in response to Christians
because all throughout Enoch, Enoch is
not the son of man. He sees the son of
man and he knows he's not the son of man
and he has to ask who is he. But all of
a sudden the son of man and Enoch are
one and the same. So that's why there
are scholars who say the original form
of Enoch did not have that section. It
was added later as a response to
Christians saying no Jesus is not the
son of man. Enoch is. And that's
reflected in later Jewish tradition
where Enoch becomes Metatron, the lesser
Yahweh, Yahawah Hakatan, who bears the
names of Yahweh and has 70 of the names
of Yahweh. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So you see this is a Jewish polyical
response trying to refute the Christian
belief that Jesus son of man. So they
made Enoch the son of man. So that's
possible explanation why later in Enoch
there's a contradiction because if you
read earlier Enoch sees the son of man
and wonders who he is and he knows
that's not him and the angels tell him
well that's the son of man who's been
there before creation who's been named
before creation will appear in the
latter days. So Enoch clearly is not the
son of man in chapters 40 to 48 other
parts of the book but then at the end he
and the son of man are one and the same.
So that's why some people think this was
an interpolation added or it can mean
that the son of man unites with Enoch
because the son of man is the heavenly
counterpart to Enoch that he is Enoch's
angel and then he unites with them to
become one with him. Either way, you
just answered your own objection. Did
you hear what you just told me? Well,
yeah, it contradicts uh New Testament.
So, how the hell is it going to be in
the Bible?
>> I don't know. It was in the Dead Sea
Scrolls as well. Not that section. No,
the only section of Enoch is the first
section called the book of watchers.
The entire book of Enoch does not exist
in the Dead Sea Scrolls. It's the first
section that doesn't have the section
where Enoch sees the son of man or
becomes a son of man. It's called the
book of Watchers. That section with the
son of man and the section where Enoch
and the son of man become one and the
same. That is from copies of Enoch that
are after the time of Christ and mostly
in Coptic copies.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> So, did you get your answer now or no?
Are you okay?
>> Um, I got the answer for that question.
Yeah.
>> Okay. What's the other question before I
smash my head against Timmy? Um, were
the epicical
gospels like
>> the gospels that are not in the Bible,
were they canon before um like 600 or
700? Because
>> what canon?
>> Um because Muhammad's quoted the the
clay bird which is not in the original
gospels that's in the Bible. What gospel
could be canon? No, because you're
assuming the what they call the infancy
gospel of Thomas or the Arabic infancy
gospel or a pseudo infancy gospel of
Matthew what or pseudo Matthew that
these were considered to be canonical
gospels part of the church's canon. How
when the only gospels that we have from
the time of Christ are Matthew, Mark,
Luke and John. No [clears throat] other
gospels come from the first century.
Every other gospel is either second
century, 3rd century or even later. And
these gospels that have stories about
the child Jesus, they are from sources
that are second century, 3rd century,
4th century. Why would any Christian
include them in the canon when one
criteria, a criterion for a book to be
considered part of the New Testament is
what's called apostolicity.
Meaning it has to come from the period
of time when the apostles are on earth
with their disciples receiving
revelation from the Holy Spirit.
>> Okay. Uh so all right.
>> You with me there. But what you're
confusing is
>> whether it's canonical and whether
Christians read these books. Yeah.
Christians read these books. And
Muhammad would hear these Christians
refer to these stories orally. But not
being educated, he thought that these
stories had some historical basis in the
life of Christ. So it doesn't have to be
canonical for it to be read. Just like
what you said about Enoch, obviously
Enoch must have been popular that even
the Jews
would have a copy of it in the Dead Sea
Scrolls and that Jude would reference
it. So you can have books that are
influential and read but not part of the
cannon. You with me there? Yeah, I I
hear you now. So, it's not meant to be
taken literally.
>> Yes. Well, what do you mean literally?
What do you mean not literally?
>> Oh, I mean not meant to be interpreted
as doctrine.
>> Okay. You mean it was not accepted as
historical, right?
>> Yeah, that's what I meant.
>> So, Yep. Exactly. Meaning though people
read it and some probably even believe
that these were actual events in the
life of Jesus in his childhood the fact
is the fact is that it could never been
considered canonical because it didn't
come from the first century and did not
spread widely by the time of the start
of the second century. When you go to
the second century, the whole Christian
world is aware of the canonical gospels
because when these go written, they were
spread all over the then Christian
world. That's why you don't have a
dispute about their authorship. No one
denied Matthew wrote Matthew, Luke wrote
Luke and Acts as well. Mark wrote Mark
or John wrote John.
Oh, I thought the Bible was made in like
the third century when the the the group
of fathers got together, but it wasn't
being prosecuted and then it became the
whole Bible.
>> Third century, not fourth century, 300s,
but beyond that, what were they reading
>> in the second century?
>> What were they reading?
>> Who?
>> The Christians, man. [laughter] What
were they?
>> Um, how did they know about Jesus?
Because they make met up and
read the gospels.
>> What? Which one? What?
>> They read the gospels and they they met
up.
>> But you just told me that didn't happen
until the third century, which you meant
fourth century.
>> So then that by the second century,
these gospels already circulating
worldwide and accepted early on as long
as well as the letters of Paul.
Oh,
>> I just thought that they're getting
killed for it in like Roman stuff.
They got killed. What?
>> He's getting malted in Rome.
>> What has that got to do with what were
the Christians reading in the second
century?
>> Okay, my bad. I'm I'm stupid.
scriptures, Old Testament books, and
books that were passed on by the
apostles and their successors to the
churches. So that by the time of the
second century, the Christians worldwide
already accepted and knew Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John.
>> All right, my bad.
>> All right, any other question?
>> Uh, not at this moment.
>> You're a good man, Zachary.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, come back with more questions
because every time I meet someone like
you, less time in purgatory for me.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. All right, brother.